today's video has been sponsored by
ubisoft
i'm always hesitant when i approach
movies and games that are set in some
kind of mythological world
because a lot of the time it feels like
an afterthought
it's also rather difficult to find the
balance between paying homage to the
original stories
and still branching out and creating
something new
when ubisoft approached me about
discussing immortals phoenix rising
a new action-adventure game rooted in
greek mythology
i was definitely intrigued i had no idea
what to expect but i was more than happy
to give it a try
after playing phoenix rising for about
five minutes it was pretty clear this
was a game and story
designed with greek mythology at its
very core
if i'm being honest i thought i'd find
myself nitpicking the narrative and the
way the characters were portrayed
but there wasn't much i disagreed with
it was definitely an
encouraging start knowing that the team
behind this clearly cared about the
source material
for those intrigued about the story i'll
give you a brief summary without any
major spoilers
the game begins with a monologue from
typhon who tells us he's going to
destroy the gods and start a new world
those of you familiar with greek
mythology will know typhon
is the closest the greek gods ever came
to being destroyed
along with some other attempts from the
giants and the tysons
so having typhon as the big bad villain
of this game
is something i wholeheartedly agree with
you'd need an antagonist the gods are
scared of
and that can only really be typhon
having defeated the gods and heroes
there is no hope left
as even the humans have all been turned
to stone barring one of course
who washes up on the shores of the
golden isle it is down to you
phoenix to reunite the gods and stop
typhoon destroying
everything one of my favorite parts of
the game that does bring up
multiple points of discussion is the
relationship between
zeus and prometheus who serve as the
primary narrators of the game
as well as helping to establish an
overall tone
zeus and prometheus have somewhat of a
troubled history
which began with prometheus stealing
fire and giving it to mankind
zeus not being a big fan of humans then
chains him to a mountain where an
eagle would swoop down and devour his
liver only for it to regenerate in the
evening and the process to repeat itself
given the situation you'd expect a
rather large amount of animosity between
them
but that's not really the case as both
characters offer comedic relief as well
as guiding you through an
unknown world after typhon's monologue
were taken to the mountain where
prometheus is chained
and he tells zeus of a prophecy a human
mortal will unite the gods and defeat
typhon zeus naturally scoffs at the idea
and even wages prometheus his freedom if
he is correct
and so begins the split narration as you
journey through the golden isle
prometheus narrates the bulk of your
story
and zeus just does zeus things most of
the time he interrupts to be an a-hole
which is a very zeus thing to do the two
do a very good job explaining
stories that relate to whatever quest
you may be doing but it doesn't feel
like a constant
dump of exposition sometimes they'll
start an explanation
only to go completely off topic and
start arguing with each other over
something ridiculously petty
i really enjoyed the constant banter
between the two it gave the game its own
charm
and it showed a good deal of
self-awareness because trying to make a
game based on greek mythology
in a completely serious tone with no
humor
is just the wrong approach considering
how weird and wacky greek mythology can
be at times it may work for a game
such as god of war where the gods exist
just to be butchered by kratos so
there's no need to get to know them
here however phoenix and the gods are on
the same side
so you need the gods to be relatable or
have some redeeming qualities
otherwise you'll just end up rooting for
typhon
to say that immortals is full of jokes
and puns
is the understatement of the year you
can't go five minutes without someone
making a joke or just
doing something comical a good portion
of this comes from zeus and hermes
who for me are big highlights of this
game some people
may not like that approach but i do
having a witty and light-hearted tone
suits the personalities of most of the
gods
it also gives the game a more fun and
chill vibe
as opposed to being stressed and anxious
all the time which isn't what i
personally want from a game that offers
so much story and
exploration the exploration and world
design
is something that really surprised me
when you hear a game tell you
it's open world normally that just means
vast
open spaces that all look the same and
often feel quite empty
phoenix rising doesn't try to make its
world feel vast for the sake of it
instead it's quite a compact map it's
not particularly large in comparison to
other games
but it is absolutely jam-packed of
things to do
at no point did i find myself running
from a to b
for hours with nothing to do along the
way there is always some kind of
creature
collectible quest or event to take part
in
each zone has its own distinct look with
four of them representing a specific
deity
athena ares aphrodite and hephaestus
you can walk into a zone and within a
few seconds of just looking around
you can tell which god's domain you've
entered
the game also doesn't hold your hand
when you enter a zone there is no quest
log
you have to find the point of interest
and solve any puzzles along the way by
yourself
as it should be also i haven't mentioned
it yet but the game just looks really
nice
which makes you want to explore it
definitely has that stylized breath of
the wild feel to it while still
maintaining its own
vibrant aesthetic moving swiftly on to
the enemies and mythical creatures you
encounter
as typhon has already ravaged much of
the world most of the human soldiers you
encounter have been brought back as
shades
and this is the case for the greek
heroes also you encounter the likes of
achilles heracles odysseus
and atalanta but they aren't quite
themselves
and it's up to you to free them from
typhon's hold
as for mythical creatures if it exists
in greek mythology
then it's probably in this game i've
come across everything from
harpies gorgons cyclopes griffins
minotaurs chimera hydra hekatonkries and
even cerberus each creature has their
own unique feel and characteristics
each time i heard a high-pitched shriek
i knew it could only be a
wretched harpy and i took way too much
pleasure in guiding my arrows into their
disgusting bird face before they were
plucked out the sky
not a huge fan of harpies if you didn't
guess the combat system in this game as
a whole
isn't very hard and it's pretty fun once
you've mastered most of the mechanics
you can deal with these creatures
pretty easily that being said when
you've just started some of these
creatures can be daunting on the harder
difficulties
i remember leaving the tutorial portion
of the game and picking a fight with the
first cyclops i found
which wasn't the best choice considering
i had no idea what i was doing
after being thrown around with a slither
of hp and no pomegranates to heal
i had only one choice i had to find the
cheesiest way to kill this cyclops
because i was not about to be bested by
the first one-eyed big dumb dumb i came
across
so i did what any fearless warrior would
do in my position
i hid behind a rock and fired arrows at
him for about five to ten minutes until
he died
i don't know if the ai in this case was
just bad or if the cyclops ai is
designed to be dumb
but it felt like an authentic encounter
with a cyclops
this is something that happens
throughout the game your interactions
with creatures
gods and even the environment just have
an authentic
feel immortal certainly puts its own
spin on greek mythology
but never does it feel as if these
stories have been diluted or changed to
fit the narrative
it's clear the narrative was built
around these stories and legends
whether you're well versed in greek
mythology or someone who knows very
little
immortals does its best to appease both
audiences
although i didn't necessarily learn
anything new that didn't really affect
my enjoyment of the game
i constantly found myself listening for
references and searching for easter eggs
which
there is no shortage of in this game on
the opposite
end if you're someone who knows very
little by the end of the game that won't
be the case anymore
as far as gateways into greek mythology
go phoenix rising does a really good job
if you enjoy greek mythology and you
just want to relax and play something
fun that has a touch of nostalgia then i
recommend phoenix rising
if you've always wanted to dive into the
world of greek mythology but didn't know
where to start
then give phoenix rising a try
you